this is a production of Cornell
University in genomics in biology and in
agriculture but the question is you know
what what is the regulatory pathway for
those products and what's the consumer
comp which the consumer pathway for
consumer acceptance I don't think I'm
going to give you all the answers today
I'm going to provide you only with some
new information about what's going on
around those topics and I'll give you
some of my thoughts about where I think
you need to go and and you know produce
therefore a little bit of where I think
it will go the future but hopefully
provide you a little some different way
to think about these topics as you go
forward and a lot of the work that's
done here for now so with that I'm going
to jump right in I'm gonna set the stage
a little bit just by the G company what
are the different applications there's
much about that and then I'm going to
talk I narrowly spent a lot of time on
the regulatory situation both you ask
well give my thoughts on where that
should move forward and then talk about
consumer acceptance and transparency of
products of this technology with some
final thoughts um so what are what did
you think what are we talking about
we'll talk about today and she do you
know anything is really the ability to
make specific genomic changes in support
isn't she know where we can identify a
specific location and then identify
specific kind of alteration we might
want in that location in the genome but
it could be an insertion of DNA Alicia
point mutation we don't swap um and it
really does take advantage of the
natural process so there are a number of
different tools gene editing tools that
are used to gene edit a genome we have
the finger
Allen crispers which I put in red
because that's the one that everybody
seems to talk about these days today but
I also put down at the end of the slide
and there are others and there will be
others in the future I think if I give
this thought five years of now there
probably will be one or two other gene
editing tools that have been added to
that toolbox so as a lawyer as a
regulator when I think about you're not
just going to do that the science is
going to keep evolving that it's going
to keep changing out of your dress so I
really wanted to point that out this
isn't a problem and I also wanted to
point out just a little bit about what
gets done because what gets done we
helped us think about how consumers
might accept it regulators like to buy
so this is my one slide that I stole
from somebody so we look at the green
part of the DNA here this is the part of
the that you want to edit so we set up
an RNA molecule that has that sting
animation here now his base pair
associated with it enzyme that cuts
through that we take that complex put it
into the cell it finds the DNA match and
it goes in cuts and at that point we
either like normal occupation before we
get to add DNA at that point you could
also put in a specific piece of DNA that
we want to introduce which could be a
whole new gene or it could be a portion
of a gene or code or whatever it wanted
at that stage in the genome so that's
what we're talking about we've done
about gene editing and I want to mention
that not all gene editing is the same
and that I think is very important to
the discussion so you can become a
tagine from the same organism or from a
different organism with gene editing
tools we could have a humanized in one
location or we can even delete if you do
size of one location of
or a huge analogy so so not all
gene-editing is the same you're the
discussion around the regulation of it a
lot of times there is this sort of
thought it's all one thing they're doing
the second thing but that's not the case
finally I just want to put this in
context so gene-editing may be the most
recent way to alter plants and animals
in agriculture but we've been you know
scientists have been using a lot of
different techniques to modify plans
have changed the genomes of plants for
traits that are evaluated to agriculture
and this slide so just you know sets
forth a number of those different things
you know when I think about these I've
got a really bad job in this slide
convey to you all but when you look at
all these techniques now they've gotten
to the point where they all blur
together it's no longer able to think
about them on a straight-line continue
on to some extent so here we have
different kinds of genes we have you
know more classical things like
chemicals or radiation pewter Genesis we
have genetic engineering GMOs its
antigenic we have some of the different
gene editing things but I put them on
which one you know which of these are
more controllable or less controllable
we can add a gene with these techniques
but we can also add it with this
technique so these things begin to mold
together on the continuum begin to sort
of hard to differentiate which is a
lawyer become typically good laws and
regulations like that freight line
definitions and it's very hard to have a
bright line definition anymore so
recently the World Economic Forum came
out with a deeper a white paper on vinyl
innovation I just wanted to quote a
couple words of this we're talking about
this idea of enemy they say there's a
green intervention make up a more
continuous spectrum determining low
versus high levels of genetic alteration
natural versus artificial outcomes with
low versus high risk cases this is
becoming a question of judgment on a
continuous spectrum
therefore depends
other type of graduated change in
organism editing to produce a product
identical two-month the three
traditional be tentative orthogonal to a
transgenic GMO no longer other clear
directions for transgenic at its
conventional practice biotechnology and
other methods and so forth and so on I
think that really captures this idea
that these things are all blending
together to some extent and you can't
make those big decisions so with that I
want to briefly just talking about some
of the applications are out there so
everybody understanding so we have lots
of things in the pipeline on the plant
side things like high delayed
soybeans crew Gina a company Alex a high
fiber weeds also from comics we have
lower saturated canola oil beef
scientists working on citrus greening
here's a citrus citrus greening disease
using CRISPR we have scientists working
on usaba resistant to Brown Street virus
using this and we're talking about in
the top center the United States Asakusa
development countries people trying to
prevent chocolate from extinction using
CRISPR so a number of things on the
plant side
considerably we have things on the
animal side the hornless cattle is the
one that gets the most press down there
I'm taking the allele from dairy cattle
from Angus and from Angus cattle that
are normally heartless and I could put
that into dairy cattle and so that's an
example out there we have one CRISPR
that was done to use a lower back pain
and also
swine virus so a number of things I
could have put out forty more slides for
things that are all pipeline I know the
question with all these becomes a lot of
these are proven concept which of these
will actually so with that background I
wanted to now get into so the regulation
and sort of what is the I'm going to
talk about now
what is current situation in both the US
and other countries but the times that I
look at district the Tories debate that
goes on as a light switch and most of
the faith that's going on is the
question is is the g- product of TMO
which is its regulated light switches on
or is it not edgy about it's not
regulated and that is my characterize
that I think that's going on around the
world that's the debate that's happening
so far the answer to that is unclear
okay most countries it's pretty still
unclear what that is and clearly if we
look at all the 200 countries around the
world that if there's not a clear thing
of things the light switch being on or
the likes repeat Bop so with that
process what's the story in the u.s.
mandatory system and take away from the
electric the Tory system is currently it
treats g'head in products the same as a
GMO okay I'm going to repeat that it
treating other products the same as a
GMO in outfit thank you bye okay from a
legal perspective so in order to do that
you have a little understanding of
United's forty miles so u.s. regulations
didn't engineered crops under the plant
Protection Act and I've always been
driven to know all this or on
regionalist
but Plant Protection Act is how they
regulate them what they pissed orally
said was you can't release the key to
your crop it's in the environment
without getting the permit from us today
under the Plant Protection Act and
eventually you regulate that so that
farmers can grow these permits anymore
there trigger their legal trigger what
the laws protecting is plant pests so
the law of trying to protect the
environment agriculture environment from
introduction of plant pass into the
environment and so the trigger has been
that a GM crop could be a potential
plant s and everywhere needed to be
regulated and primarily that was based
on the fact that the transformation
vehicle the way you got the new gene
into the plant that new trade that was
engineered was through hydro bacteria
and I grow bacteria does
isn't listed micro bacterium infects
plants and causes diseases and so that
was the traditional way that they got
the regulation so I can sit here today
and say before 2010 all genetic engineer
crops were regulated hygienic engineered
crop unites agent research at a place
like Cornell you couldn't do that
research outside of the laboratory
without any permit from USDA after 2010
it depends
not all Gina not all GMOs or genetically
engineered crops which are commodified
popular want to call them are currently
regulated at USGS if you use that grow
bacterium as your transformation that
are regulated but if you use the gene
gun you're not regulated because the
gene gun holistically pushes that DNA
into the cell and you're not using a
plant pest so contrary to what people
think that all GMOs are regulated ok and
here's an example so there's a dredge a
sorghum that they developed by series
biotech company and they went to USDA
means that you know we introduced a
foreign gene a gene from a different
species into our sorghum are we
regulated and the USDA said in a letter
back you can use any plant pests in your
construct or in your method of
transformation so you are not regulated
and there are a number of other sorts of
other examples up there none of them are
commercial products yet as far as I'm
aware of but there are other things in
the pipeline that USPS said won't be
regulated so but one of your takeaways
is not all GMOs are regulated in States
by USDA
similarly people researchers who are
developing gene headed across I've also
gotten the USDA and said am i regulated
so the non ground mushroom the most
popular ones
popular press use crisper and state
research he was CRISPR to make adnan
browning to silence a feed and USDA said
you didn't use any plant pests in the
process
CRISPR itself CRISPR molecule is not a
plant pass
and so we're not going to rate the later
and similar they said that for years own
camelina oil that was used because
forecast night with you that and again I
could put up ugly couple dozen of these
that have gone through this a my
regulated process today and said that
they're not regularly so so you'd say
well and as far as I know they've not
said that anymore regulated in fact I'm
so Secretary Purdue made a statement
earlier this year where he said and this
is from the press release us does not
regulator have any plans for a date
otherwise have been developed in
traditional breeding techniques as long
as they are not planned pasture develop
using by a mess so and he gives the
example of genome editing so he
specifically said so sort of
memorializes but USDA have been doing
signing as long as it's as long as
there's no plant ask involved it's not
going to be regulate and they then went
on to talk about things that would could
be included with the deletion signal
base pairs of stars and so on but again
they also have this this caveat of it
that we developed that could be
developed with traditional breeding text
which they didn't define so so that's
the current regulatory system in USDA
FDA also regulates genetically
engineered or all our troops and they
currently have a voluntary consultation
process for genetic class where they
will get the genetic engineer plant and
compare it to its vegetable counterpart
and ask whether they're substantially
equivalent and today you know there's no
reason not to believe that every single
developers out there that's been through
that voluntary process and that was what
the government I suppose the same thing
for gene editing Christ saying you're
not required to come in but you could
come in associated but they didn't see
that the phenotypic disadvantage bullets
who its conventional counterpart on the
animal size there is a mandatory
pre-market approval process currently
frisson have to execute animals they
have done under the new animals blood
provision
a new animal drug is defined as anything
that alters the structure or function of
an animal and if you add a gene or you
change the genetics of the cell
you are altering the structure of that
cell you're altering the structure of
that DNA and so they interpreted that we
can argue whether that's a good
interpretation or not they've
interpreted that to say therefore
changing the DNA not adding up a key
changes the structure or function of the
animal coming to be different the amount
of mother-approved they also propose the
same treatment 14 other data they said
if you change if you intentionally
change a base pair of the DNA of an
animal you are creating a new animal
drug and therefore it also these
particular so that is a proposal that
hasn't been finalized this
administration has been they've drawn
that proposal but they also haven't said
in yours of things so instead we're
looking into this how we're going to
regulate gene editing products
holistically and they haven't really
announced anything so that's the most
recent pronouncement from FDA on this
topic so when I look at those together
and there's another agency genetic
engineering profit of pesticides today
um when I look at this regulatory system
what observations do I get well it's not
particularly science or Mis based and
I'll argue that it either has
over-regulation currently and my example
is so if I change one base pair of a
genetic u of a G go to the crop it's a
voluntary consultation process but if I
change one base pair of an animal it's
on the inventory pre-market approval
process I find it hard to argue that
changing one base pair in two different
species can have that very a risk
profile that one does a very high level
scrutiny and oversight and one has very
low levels somewhere along the line
somebody is being over regulated or
somebody's been under regular similarly
that we compare to GM of
in the USDA instance if I use the gene
gun to introduce a gene to stop citrus
greening it's not regulated if I use I
grow bacterium to introduce that same
gene all night and the same genotype it
is regulated and if I get the same
phenotype by the leading and silencing
of genes gene editing I get the same
phenotype and it's not regulated and so
again somewhere along the line topics
either be over regulated by the
regulator so it's hard to argue that
this is a science-based risk-based
system whatever your view is of whether
things should be regulated or not
regulated the system is existing I think
has lots of flaws in it I also want to
point out that it's not related to
foreign DNA in the debate over whether
something - chiumbo or not the always
issue is did we introduce some foreign
DNA into it the US regulatory system
plays no role whether it's foreign DNA
or it's whether it's a plant pest
whether it's a food you know after a lot
of other triggers but the trigger is not
whether you have it okay and so what you
have is and that's why I argue they're
treating GMOs and gene and it's the same
from a legal perspective that using the
same laws and the same interpretations
of those bars but when they apply them
to the different products you get
different results
so what you'll get is most GMOs and get
regulated by USDA but most genetic
products are not going to get rid of it
not because they've been exempt or if
I'm insane but because they don't use I
grow bacteria where they don't use quiet
past whereas GMOs use the plant pest but
if the gene edited did use a plant
density at a plant pest associated with
it it would be Rachel and similarly
emotions are regulated so you get
different results because they're their
legal trigger any change in the DNA
applies equally for both genetically
modified animals she so that's why I say
that they are treated the same legally
and regulatory but the outcome may be
different
I to the facts so what's the regulatory
situation in other countries again the
debate is is the light switch on the
light switch off so I switched directly
to the European heard that was a big
issue if there was a court case in front
of the European Court of Justice brought
by a French an NGO that went to a French
Court at the French Court certified the
issue to the European Court of Justice
which said are gene-editing
props covered by the GMO law the GMO
directive in Europe and this past July
the European Court of Justice said yes
they are cover and what they did and I
want to spend a minute on it because I
think it's understood by a lot of people
what they said was it was pretty much
just I did a pretty standard
interpretation on the law so a lot of
people wrote a lot of articles were
written about this flame well this guy's
up I hope they did made a science
determination they pretty much five law
complement determine as they interpreted
a law that there's a critique of this
decision the critique is that Parliament
wrote a law that was overly broad
actually provision for this technology
not that the European Court justice kind
of probably law but what the court
appearances did was so GMO under the
directive is an organism in which the
genetic material is altered in a way
that does not hurt naturally by mating
or natural recombination so that's the
definition and under that definition
things like mutagenesis are included as
GMOs under that normal but they're
exempt from the requirements of that law
they don't involve the use of
recombinant DNA molecules are GMOs
so the concept is chemical oogenesis
irradiation they do produce a GMO under
the definition but they're exempt
because they don't and what the your big
doses court knows is that that in the in
the law that Parliament at Parliament
said the reason they did that was these
these other techniques they
conventionally used a number of
applications to have a policy to
record so that was a finding of fact on
the European Parliament and so the new
European Court Justice said well then
the only really congressman conventional
mutagenic for the long history of safety
and Christopher is a new technique
without that long history of safety so
it doesn't qualify for what they meant
that exclusion to include so you know we
can argue about what they should have
what should be the proper role in the
court wasn't so out of place and I did a
lot of good welcome Joe if you want to
read more about that detail they are not
the only court that's done at some you
zealand as a law about gmos their
hazardous substance and you organize and
they're a GMO is defined as any organism
of any of the genes or other genetic
material has been modified by Hindi from
techniques it's pretty hard to argue
that gene editing is not easy for
technique okay that's part of my DNA and
to something that that's what the quirky
food it said okay I'm on this basis that
signature 1p become more postal order
combination and therefore are covering
under the law so they went back to this
definition and we don't even let should
be the definition of oh or a definition
for a genetically altered
kind of organism but that's what they
were doing so so we have in the
international context several countries
whose laws have been interpreted to
include as GMO
we also have countries like Argentina
which is triple largest in this step
we're gonna look at this a case-by-case
basis but when you go through their
analysis and this may be a little hard
to read but what they're saying is if
you've done a gene that a big drop you
do an early consultation with the
biosafety committee and they're going to
ask you is there a new combination of
genetic material involved in it and if
it is that they say yes it's a GMO
if it's not they're gonna ask cloud you
user fans and is there transgene at the
final product and if there's no Trinity
in the final products and no new DNA in
the final product that it's not going to
be covered and so pretty much it there
is there warranty in their house there's
no foreign DNA in the final product even
if there is an intermediary products
that it's not likely to doesn't she I'm
up and you go through an assessment to
comment that so that's what they've done
in several other South American
countries Brazil we have countries like
Israel that also have a similarly
similar regulatory system what they're
saying is Walmart on DNA sequences in it
then it's not being regulated but you
and I can also sit out of discussion
about but that's really good scientific
may be a good way to deal with the
regulatory situation but you know it's
an all DNA DNA we have genes from other
species and other species have genes in
them from other places and so you know
what is far in this understand we you
know we do that's a fair discussion
about that countries like Japan not made
a decision yet but a government
committee I said there's certain forms
of G never do again most if I when we
give that means single base pair of
deletions but not those more complex
things might not be regulated the United
Kingdom interestingly when they were
asked about GM teen editing they argue
to European community that if the
changes of the DNA could have occurred
naturally or the traditional breeding
then they would not be during it was
similar to what occurred naturally
traditional breeding such as a single
point mutation then it shouldn't be
regulated as a GMO that's what they
argue scientifically but they also said
when they were leaving projects but they
would incorporate the GMO laws of the
Union into the new UK lost because they
didn't want to the offset trade with the
EU and they wanted to say that they were
reducing their food safety laws that
their environmental laws so they're
citizens and so now they're in a
quandary because with the European Court
they exhibit their apology no law and
the Teemo law says that cheetah are GMOs
we'll see where that ends up and then
you have other countries that I don't
think it even got a decision yet but if
you look at their definition of the
Philippines saying and she opposes any
novel combination of genetic material
thank you modern biotechnology that is a
lawyer
hoping the logic interpretation Ghana
says an organism that had his own gene
modified without the insertion hard to
argue under that definition you've seen
how to make using any genes modified and
you don't even have to add anything to
do it just the fact that it's been
modified covers it and then we have the
international agreement in this area
that coordinated by our safety protocol
which says that modern biotechnology is
individually play acid techniques I
think gene editing qualifies as an
individual a gadget technique the
question becomes doesn't overcome
natural production recombination
barriers are not techniques using
traditional breeding clearly is not one
use the traditional breeding but it
produces things similar to traditional
breeding how does that interpretive
unclear in my mind the lawyer so that's
why I said the regulatory situation I
think overall is unclear around the
world there's still many decisions to be
made and even in the countries that we
think are clear they're still not I
think the final word so what are some
observations and so I think when you
look at this the government stakeholders
with a population they discuss $2.99 a
month but other things are regulated
based on sort of three triggers they
asked whether there's foreign DNA or
entity in the final product whether the
additive the motive is or could have
been found in nature or whether the edit
could have introduced to conventional or
traditional breeding chemical
mutagenesis or radiation
I'm I'm not sure any of those triggers
actually pulls up as a scientific matter
they may hold up as a legal matter but
I'm not sure they really pulled up as a
lawyer
I find things like our DNA or AB in
nature or conventional or traditional to
know what the boundaries of those things
are but that is where the debate is
going and that leads to this question of
whether that's on or off um I don't
think my personal view is that a binary
option is a high-risk game because the
likelihood of 180 countries all turning
the light switch off is near zero and
once you have a few countries turning it
on then you run into trade issues and
other issues in it and so and and and
when the legs which goes on to get this
whole level of oversight that probably
isn't relevant is it the latest of the
risk profile did she get a big cross so
you're trying to push the editing into
two different options
neither which fits well the gene editing
and so you're putting square pegs into
round holes and you're making a binary
decision I just think that's going to
end up in a bad situation overall do
that interestingly Bill Gates had an
article in a journal awhile ago
or talk about 2008 one of the things he
said which I liked about it was you know
rule to know that need to go for other
formula to make the treat don't
necessarily fit I think that's the that
is the key here that we're trying to fit
something that doesn't fit and so and
we're doing that in a very risky bag so
my ideas we need to broaden that
discussion between those two options the
regulation can take many forms and we
have many different kinds of gene of it
we have a silence gene versus 12 silence
genes to produce a metabolic pathway
versus adding DNA versus from one
species from different species and so we
want more of a science-based crisp
system that has a number of different
buckets forgive them different
categories for different types of
products and so the questions you should
be asking are one of the potential risks
anything from the process one of the
potential risks and anything from the
product state using that process how
does that risk profile compare to other
articles will breeding techniques and
products and then if there are visits
that need regulation
what system would be proportionate to
those risks and set up a system based on
those potential risks for those
categories of products that's not what's
going on
interestingly Bloomberg a territorial
that I'd really like I didn't tell them
about this but it's sort of said the
same thing so it was saying a better
approach then is a middle course rather
than three just the products of a
technology regulators your screen and
single on those that might need special
monitoring of restrictions the idea that
we should have a mandatory system but we
should help smooth the way but that it
wouldn't be either of the systems we
have currently on so that's why I go for
this proportionate risk based system and
I'll leave you with this sort of an
example and this is my basis for this is
okay so we have three different products
all three of these products are made in
the pipeline I can't tell you they will
make it out to the market or not but
here we have one gene editing cold
storage potato calyx is using talons and
they've inactivated a single gene so
they silenced the single gene to bridge
this old data we also have another
biotech company that has turned off
three genes to make a hypoallergenic
peanut okay we use the opportunity of
peanuts and we have a third Institute
this one in Spain that's used whisper to
35 different teams 35 different genes
and they're making a gluten reduced
beets so the question is do these three
things have the same level of risk do
they deserve the state level of
oversight I don't think they do this one
I may have no problem with we can just
get to no oversight no need for a risk
assessment don't need any government
oversight and they could just stuff a
registry of what's happening here you
know my food safety hat comes on and
says I really want to trust this company
that this is allergen free or do I want
the government cooking and making sure
before that gets out there that that's
an allergen free beyond and that's not
to cause people to go to the hospital as
an allergen illness and this one again
do I worry about the food safety issue
and we starting with 35 genes are there
any other things that have happened
because the clock
you know that we want somebody checking
that out
so my view is these three things get
three different levels of oversight um
they don't get the same but the system
that we proposed would either treat all
of these has no oversight whatsoever for
all of them is GMOs and I think that's
what this is for I think so I put this
final quote that by infinite innovation
report that's a populist idea that you
want
appropriate regulation proportionate
oversight actually helps developers
bring products to market and an
independent assessment gives consumers
trust if you have an overly stringent
one with costly regulation that prevents
things have grown through the
marketplace and can cause and there's no
oversight consumers question the safety
so we've got to figure out that balance
in this situation if there is no federal
regulation what I have we could have
state oversight there are states that
could have regulation I think your pops
I'm sure they get regulate gene editing
drops so we do have some states
California Minnesota others begin to
regulate this is that better having
different states doing things that have
we clearly will have other countries
because I can't guarantee but not
everybody can do it so what will be the
trade impacts of that we still need some
level of organization and do we want the
fact of China so save me don't regulated
here and trying to regulate it our
partners and behold it before China
proves it too they get to college one of
the good things about regulation of GMOs
we talked about is we regulated here a
lot of countries defer to our
regulations so Korea and Japan others
look at armistice definitely say we
don't need to do a second one but we're
not doing anything
who are they going to rely upon and if
they don't agree with us that it needs
no regulation and they may be like my
China for the EU and do we want that or
we'd rather be the leaders saying what
is the level of oversight that goes on
so I'll leave you with that I want to
talk a little bit about consumer
acceptance I think what consumers care
the most about is an assurance of safety
transparency
official products so what a different
stakeholders the same as you might
imagine a lot of the anyhow who said no
this this achieved in genetic
engineering 2.0 they said that this is
being promoted the same way they saying
it's the same using dependence on case
and so they are only for regulation and
calling for people not to be punished
like this the National Organic Standards
Board voted in 2016 to make a
recommendation that you must be a G
nothing the excluded methods securing
that has not been accepted yet by the
administration partly organic standards
but you can see where they're felling
and you have you know the non-gmo
project pretty much saying these are
GMOs and we're not going to include them
on the gears their Twitter don't be
fooled products across from new tech
like Tina dating survival are GMOs so
either way whether there's regulation or
not and whether the consumer acceptance
or not there's going to be a
differentiation in the marketplace
that's already happening
you already see that with some products
that non-gmo project the organic
community and you know to some extent
many consumers may not understand these
legal signs of extinctions you know you
start explaining to them G nothing they
said there's something about saying oh
it's going to be very hard to make that
distinction and is the foreign gene
distinction may be important for
regulation whether that will be as
important River acceptance is I think an
open question so you know to me the
factors for consumer acceptance are has
it been conveyed by an independent party
these are the questions that extraverts
are going to ask as if it sounds age by
the independent party are there benefits
and who benefits doesn't finish their
view of food if there's a sustainability
and what an influential people they
respects a I'm not saying that those
aren't easy to answer I think there will
be many consumers whose role except gene
other than products but I do think that
there's going to be some discussion
about it on the issue of transparency I
think
learned as if something didn't [ __ ]
supers they want robot you know didn't
there's some reason it's hidden and for
consumers you want to know which I think
was a very small segment of the
population the information needs to be
available so if there's no regulation
out of the food chain supplies my
thought is being in the National
Register so if it's not rounding
mushroom is out there a supermarket
chain like Wegmans can go look and say
oh there are mom brownie monsters out
there consumer asks I don't look at
transparency as labeling but I do look
at it is the ability to know what's out
there and so forth one other thing that
I think will impact consumer acceptance
in this area is like all the wild card
which is crisper and G I think is going
to use it human and in gene drives and
conservation areas and how is that going
to affect consumers is that point that
make them more likely to be favorable to
this or less likely
so you have research being done to
correct sickle cell anemia ID number of
different singles single point mutation
eye disease genetic diseases in humans
if they cure sickle cell anemia that
might really give this a boost it might
actually help consumers accept this in
other fields like agriculture but we're
also using gene drives and you know
eradicating bats is Meissen places like
New Zealand to end malaria if this works
again that may pave the way to
acceptance if it doesn't work or if we
start creating designer babies or other
things it could backfire and could go
the other way so I think that's
something a wild card here that people
forget about that as opposed to GMOs
which has really been I think there are
ethical issues and a lot of other issues
on other aspects of gene editing that
are gonna overflow into the under
cultural debate people from at least the
public's perception of it and one of the
interesting things which I'll leave you
but you know Commissioner Gandhi that
USDA was talking about gene editing and
talking about regulation of it
and pretty much we're saying you know um
I'm I hitting the commissioner I'm in
charge of both human make human drug
therapies as well as al-bakr therapies
and if I say that I don't regulate a
single base pair change in the animal do
I do the same thing for humans which is
the which would be the methods for
solving sickle cell anemia and how do I
make the science and when these two
essentials are applied to people I had
never heard anybody in the
administration make this argument before
but it again makes you think about the
bleeding over of these different areas
and well we may want a certain question
is an agriculture we also have to worry
that those question is how do those the
president's applying the conservation I
in the human area and I'm not saying
that it is one way the other just a
point keep in mind that that is
something that's in the minds of people
on this issue
so one of my conclusions you know I
think regulation should be made about
science risk these a regulatory
situation right now internationally is
not certain I think the existing laws
are having trouble keeping up with the
science the last thirty years they
probably say for the next thirty years
that's not you need you biotech um that
there's going to be more concern second
patients because but they're no matter
how them a visual they are and so forth
that's kind of reality and maybe a small
portion and how these techniques have
used and what products are developed
will in time Super seven I still think
in the end if it's a benefit for
consumers consumers benefits very
quickly
the question is what's the benefit for
consumers but if there's a benefit out
there that consumers perceive as a
benefit it will fly off the shelf and
nobody's gonna care about whether it's
gene edited we modify or anything
the bumbled is to date a lot of the
stuff is more effective firefighters or
others um I think in the end game
currencies
crucial all around I think we've learned
in this internet age that we're in in
this media ties to the Information Age
that without transparency people are
always going to confession
why and that's just gonna automatic
being negative start an uphill battle
that you don't need the hack so I'm
going in there the Canada has used to
have fun in Philly based on the product
or the implants as well answer that two
ways first of all the Canadian system is
right is being done novelty I would
think of at reaching out it across the
same as a prom did it's novel but the
product is novel that it could be
regulated I think they would treat GM
and GM NGO is insane while the Canadian
system is long you product based but he
had a friend diagram I'm not aware of
them ever taking a GMO it's not powerful
it doesn't get regulated so when you
look at what they've regulated under
that law you took a Venn diagram
everything everything that's been GMO
didn't has been regulated employer to
other things that are not GMO so
although it's a product based system
it's hard to argue that it really is
independent of process because they've
never exempted
comments jam up so that's just a side on
it my own take is that the product
process decision isn't a really a good
one because well we want to either look
at both you're doing a mission centering
we don't just look at the products you
also look at the process that made that
product that informs the process the
product how do you do a risk assessment
of that product so as my example before
Wilson screening you know if you used
CRISPR and you don't add a gene that
bruises a protein you don't need to take
here now but you use be made a citrus
greening one and you do introduce a gene
from peanuts then you have a food safety
issue to look at so that process it's
not just a phenotype at the end you need
to look at that genotype and that
doesn't call some process associated
with it so my regular system would have
a combination of processes one or the
other so just a comment maybe you can
respond to it seems like the whole
argument is white fish focused on
process start medicated on this human
instincts treat anything that's not
natural it's not established
conventional this is fish we asked for
this aversion to new things right
because it was not sure if they're safe
it tend to me that also sort of linked
to his sense religious right natural
god-given bounding it's healthy and safe
right and it may be somehow manipulated
business so is there is there a way to
sway public opinion
you didn't answer you know human
instincts because everybody in this room
knows that a reader in a few generations
could produce you know toxic stupid hit
right through conventional means natural
reading and then nature is interesting
is there I think so much about so much
of the process right now the due process
risk inherent process comes from this
deep innate Greensburg part of to the
nature that has an aversion this truth
to the middle so is there any chance
familiar to us we're comfortable with
things that are new or different and so
things that are novel and do be you know
raise a hand going back to your little
two-year-old you want to give them
something their usual actually say
saying you know it always exchange their
money said yes later but their initial
reaction is to say no because they don't
know what that day I think you don't
want to be on the safe side and so human
nature I think is I'm usually the state
number and so we do regulate things that
are just not willing to because they're
not willing do it eventually
if you don't do they become familiar and
there's no need to regulate and part of
that is just consumer confidence and to
let people feel comfortable with
something because they don't know about
it how do you change that
I mean part of it at the Agricultural
feeling that that makes you more aware
you know what what how I come true how
food gets to their table comes from so
one of the examples I didn't want to
talk about that what is natural to talk
ideas I give an example blue I go across
between an apricot in the claw which is
the total human invention they can't
cross that
naturally but it looks you pick it from
a tree it looks as natural as can be
it's a piece of fruit you know it came
from the tree game of the drought son
was on it water not much else and yet
you and I know that it's the farthest
thing from natural whatever natural
means
so hopefully with education we in your
life people can begin to realize that
there isn't busy while their instinct is
this big dichotomy or this big brave the
reality is in the biological world that
distinction doesn't exist
everything is continuum and therefore to
feel more comfortable with text but then
you're always going to have a hesitation
with any defense to whether it's
biological or other kinds of things
unless there's a major benefit some cell
phones everybody I go back up
pasteurization which was a new technique
used a key benefits to people eventually
became the norm so the hope is that some
of these be years ago does change but it
is little I mean I'm talking about a the
switch oh no GMO
how you make swallow holy syllables
countries where people have great
abilities
I mean sure in reference to what you
were just saying I understand that this
is always I think that speaks more to -
why are we it hasn't always worked
further and so we do need some relation
and it's not just religion or scary
science necessarily but every once in a
while I think the public is willing to
accept mistakes correct all the nine
when some of the examples that I might
get where it's really hard to college is
when things have been hit people didn't
acknowledge some of those uncertainties
or when things were found to be public
they didn't release that information and
they hold it back things like that and
that's where the public good comes very
very uncertain about things in the
future so that's why I think the change
the effects of key critical events
because I think I'm I knew is a
regulator or the scientist can get it
wrong but if they were upfront about
things the public will forgive them but
if they weren't up front about it and
they won't forgive it and it kind of
thing that's my own view on it but
that's up for debate in the end for
Africa for other countries if you have
don't have a predatory system so I think
the ones that point out most of those
laws and most other definitions we're
done before Gina even existed so the
network we're applying an old law a new
technique I think we're getting gaps and
ambiguities and not good fixes and
nobody thought about when they made
those definitions that there would be
this technique if you're doing a law now
I think you have to consider your
definition you can now understand these
other techniques and decide to include
the consciousness whether to do that so
I think that's the difference but you
also have to realize it in those
countries that ten years from now
there's going to be something else new
they're different so you have to have
unions I'm never going to go to predict
what that is but you don't want to write
your language in such a way you might
not want to capture it in future so you
have some flexibility built into that
system some of these definitions are
pretty inflexible there are countries
that by the definition for they allow
the regulator to exempt things and
modify things through regulation will be
power as these become more conventional
as people who know more comfortable as
do good regulatory systems would say to
put it's a lot of business that founder
while it's finding that everything is
saying that you dealt with the
deregulate those vacuum regulation
without having to go back to Parliament
so there are ways you can do it
hopefully we learn and we do better jobs
and power
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu